欢迎来到知行小酒馆。这是一档有知有行出品的播客节目。
我们关注投资，更关注怎样更好的生活。我是玉白。
在开始今天这期节目之前，我得好好介绍一下这位嘉宾。
对有知有行的老朋友来说，他现在才来做客。其实啊，挺奇怪的。
这个人就是张肖宇。他是有知有行的发起人之一。
几年前，我原本是在面试另外一家公司。他是面试官。
结果他把我介绍给了孟严。这才有了后面的故事。
到了有知有行，我做的第一个项目投资第一课，也是我们一起参与，一起打磨出来的。
但是很快，他就在有知有行消失了。
过去这几年，我陆陆续续在不同的地方看到他，也听不同的人提起他。
有的人是通过他在得道上的课程认识他的。
有的人是通过他写的商业文章。
有的人是因为播客得意旺行。
也有人是通过一些看起来完全不搭界的人和事。
比如歌手陈敬飞，或者网球运动员商俊成。
如果一定要用一个画面来形容他这几年的状态，
我脑海里浮现出来的是一头鲸鱼。
偶尔付出海面，但是每一次都在不同的海域。
对我来说，更重要的不是这些标签。
而是当年我们短暂共识的那段时间里，他留给我的一些思考。
那些思考在我身上慢慢发酵，也让我一直很希望有机会能和他好好聊一聊。
前段时间，他给我发了一条消息，说要不要一起录一期。
我突然意识到时机到了。
我一直很好奇，他这五年的消失，想听他好好讲讲。
这五年下来，他自己有没有发生什么变化。
这期节目上线的时候，应该是小酒馆成立五周年的时候。
之前小酒馆的老听众可能也听我提到过，我来有这种形式，
其实是因为肖宇老师。
这也是我这次跟你聊天特别想聊的一个话题。
因为我当时是在面另外一家公司的过程中。
一面是那家公司的创始人，二面是肖宇老师。
我当时是在新城国际楼下的一个咖啡馆叫到肖宇。
他一上来跟我说，我没想让你来。
我当时就傻了，我想说，你把我叫我来干吗？
然后他非常认真的，就是陷入了沉思当中。
然后他再说，我来帮你想一想你适合去什么样的地方。
就是在以前去面试嘛，要么是你通过了，要么是你没通过。
但是我没有想到还有第三种结局，就是面试官来帮你想，
基于你的能力，基于你的背景，有没有更适合你去的地方。
而且是圣身处地的替你思考。
这个事情对我有非常大的出动。
我后面，尤其是做节目做了久了，我才意识到说，
很多事情是你经历过，你才会相信。
就是比如我当时经历了这一切，来道有自由行。
我才意识到说，应该更多的去帮助他人。
我就帮助他人，给予他人一点点，比如不管是温暖，
或者是建议，也许都能够产生很多很好的效果。
其实本质上有肉行的也在做这件事。
对。这是真正的执行合议。
是。对吧。
对，当时我觉得也是一个缘分吧。
首先我觉得可能跟我做人的风格有关系。
我觉得我自己做事情，人生逻辑大于一切逻辑。
人生逻辑大于一切逻辑。
就是当我坐在这面试你的时候五年前，
这个是一个社会结构，对吧？
我是面试者，你是背面试的人。
你要找工作，我来部分的决定，你能不能找到这个工作。
这是一个社会建构的结构，把我们放在那。
但我天生很讨厌这种东西。
因为我觉得，首先我们是两个人。
你来这个公司面试，或者我在做这件事，
无非我们最终的目的不都是为了获得某种人生的幸福吗？
对吧?
就是在你的意识中，可能你找的一个好工作，
你等等等等做很多事，取得税的成功等等，
他跟你的人生幸福是挂钩了。
那我做家公司，或者我去面试，我去帮这公司发展的更好，
可能某种程度上也跟我的人生成就感幸福是挂钩了。
既然我们都是为了这件事，
那为什么不在这个层面去解决这问题呢？
因为我觉得你来这幸福不了。
然后我把你拉到这，我也不能幸福。
那何不我们在人的层面上去交流呢？
我觉得首先这是我觉得很重要的一点，
就是我永远希望我跟他人，我跟自己首先，
都是在人的这个层面上交流，才有社会身份。
否则的话，我觉得就有点没劲。
然后我也有点讨厌别人把我当成某种社会身份。
这就是为什么我这些年做了这么多事，
然后我没有一个事做得很好，
但反正我也一点不后悔，挺开心的吧，就这样。
所以我见到你，其实我对待很多人也是这样吧，
就是我一方面会看你是不是匹配一个事情，
但更重要的是我觉得这个人是不是。
应该在以不同的方式去抵达他所谓的想要那个人什么东西，
这就是有这种做的事啊。
投资是为了更好的生活，我们总说这个话，
生活才是那个终极的目标，投资是一个手段，
投资对绝大多数人来讲，
不是一个目的而是一个工具，
那就应该这么干这点事。
其实当时跟你聊天的情境我还记得挺清楚的，
就是你非常堵定的跟我说，
你在内容已经积累了非常好的能力，
然后事业也很宽，
那么你应该把这些能力放到另外一个领域，
去做一个这样的叠加或者惩罚，
然后你觉得这一种，
我说得好好啊，
对啊，说得非常好，
对，就是这样它其实才能够达到更好的效果，
你其实当时列举了很多的领域，
你只是建议我跟孟爷爷聊一聊，
你说正好有个朋友，
他缺一个人，
你可以跟他聊聊，
然后我建议你多跟不同的朋友聊聊，
我还可以给你介绍人，
结果我跟第一个人聊，我就入职了。
对，反正因为我从小就是一个偷鸡取巧的人，
因为怎么说，
我就特别不愿意，
以一种较为勤恳和踏实的方式去做事，
然后我就很多小聪明，
当然这也导致了我人生的很多所谓的失败挫折和教训，
但大家没办法，
它就是我的一部分，
所以我的出发点永远是，
既然你已经会这些东西了，
那你拿到哪儿，
它这个东西可以，
就是你在这个地儿卷，
你不如在一个特别不卷的地去发挥吗？
因为我自己看过太多这种，
你可能在A行业你干得很好，
你这个东西稍微搬到B行业，
马上这B行业就催骨拉朽，
然后你就做事什么都特别简单，
但是你回到A行业，
所有人都会把你这个东西当成一个很自然的，
你本来又应该拥有的，
天然就该具备的东西，
但是另外一个领域的人，
可能就会特别真实和欣赏，
我觉得就是要干这样的事，
就仅从功利性的角度上来讲，
明明你现在得到嘛，
然后你做了很多节目，
然后包括得到那一套方法论诺诺，
我觉得是特别特别好的，
或者说特别特别有自成体系和一套东西的，
那你这晚上你想这么多聪明人，
研究好几年，
怎么把一个老师最珍贵的知识给掏出来，
而而弄，
最后才能收人199，
你懂我意思吗？
但是你这套东西，
换到另外一个领域，
你可能完全就不是这个价值了，
就仅从投资回报的这个逻辑来讲，
所以对职业生涯我觉得也是这样嘛，
就是你积累的那套东西，
换到其他的领域里，
可能它能嫁接和释放的空间是非常大的，
所以就从职业生涯的角度，
我觉得这就是挺好的一个事，
那我自己也一直在寻找这样的事，
然后也吃我能亏嘛，
因为就是不想下苦功夫，
这就是我的人生特点，
就不爱下苦功夫。
也不想改变啊？
不想改变，
其实这样就是说，
我觉得我能看到我的这个问题，
它在一些时候是很糟糕的，
使得我会获得一些失败和教训，
那在另一方面，
又能让我在其他一些情境下，
去获得一些我想要的东西，
或者说，
按照我本源的性格去生活，
就很开心，
所以,
它就是我的一部分，
那至于我，
可能更高的智慧是，
我大概知道，
更知道什么时候使用这个，
什么时候不使用这个，
原来可能我每次都使用这个我的特点，
但以后我可能在一些不那么适合的，
事宜的场所，
我就不少使用这个东西，
我就下点苦功夫，
或者我就心甘情愿的，
别骗自己说，
OK，我现在就是没有现在还苦功夫，
但我接受它，
最简单的例子就是，
因为可能一些朋友知道我打网球，
我打了十年网球，
然后我，
特别特别热爱网球，
然后我现在也慢慢在从事一些网球行业的东西，
然后我就发现在我在打网球的过程中，
一样贯彻了我的这个，
历史性的，
习惯性的人格，
就是,
我会经常为了逃避，
做基本的事情，
做基本功的事情，
和扎扎实实去琴琴恳练的东西，
来搞一些外面邪道，
比如说，
首先,
一个很明显的点，
就是买一堆设备，
比如说腿酸了，
我就看，
一查什么NBA球员，
用什么东西恢复身体，
我就买一套，
然后买一些什么奇奇怪怪的训练工具，
然后我还发明过，
很多奇怪的学球法，
比如说，
上YouTube找那个学球的视频，
然后到我快睡着的时候，
我就打开，
然后我就一夜循环，
就夜里睡觉学，
你懂我意思吗？
就希望它进入你的潜意识，
我将潜意识跟它对话，
然后,
当然可能报名什么各种包，
反正就是总之就是说，
后来我明白了，
其实我最需要的是去，
在家进行一些，
比如说我小肌肉群的训练，
增加我的脚踝稳定性，
然后我的核心更扎实，
对吧,
但这些都很枯燥，
我就不想练，
所以我就，
进行了大量逃避的工作，
然后这个也贯穿了我的人生，
就是我，
经常使用各种方式，
逃避我要面的东西，
这是我很典型的一个模式，
其实我在我自己的上期播客也讲到的，
这个东西，
就是为了逃避一些，
你真正该面的东西，
去做很多周边的事情，
然后直到有一天你没法再逃了，
我现在说这些，
就是因为我经历的过程，
然后我，
有点,
越过山丘了，
就是说，
有一些我最想逃避，
最痛苦的东西，
我已经经历了，
或者说我已经，
部分的经历了，
仍在经历中，
然后我现在发现好像也没那么可怕，
所以我稍微，
就没有以前那么害怕了，
他语白现在，
暴露出了非常惊讶的表情，
不是,
就是现在表情是，
非常想吃瓜的表情，
对对对，
反正就是我的模式吧，
我再稍微倒回去一点点，
我还是想描述一下，
当时和小语，
就是在面试中的那种感受，
就当时我真的坐在你对面，
我非常非常的震惊，
我从来没想过一个面试官，
可以这样为我，
去思考，
完全站在我的立场，
帮我规划我的路，
我觉得是，
给我种下了一个，
非常重要的一颗，
种子,
对,
然后后面就是，
到了有志有行，
开始做投资第一颗，
小语也参与了，
转写,
然后21年之后，
你就在有志有行消失了，
对对对，
就是发生了什么，
这几年到底去哪了？
对,
稍微有一点的冤冤，
就是可能，
一部分听众知道，
应该我算是，
有志有行串棒出使的时候的，
第一批，
支持孟严的人，
对,
完全可以说是，
有志有行的发起人之一，
对,
主要还是，
都是你们的工作，
还是很得高望重的，
得高望重，
除了那名语股东，
就是在那个总统山，
对,
总统山，
当然已经没什么实权了，
当然给你一个，
对对对，
名语股东，
对,
然后也，
确实在这个事情的，
发起的过程中，
起到了一些作用吧，
而且,
特别像是我的模式，
为什么？
以前我，
以类似的模式，
支持过不同的，
一些奇怪的企业，
我在上海有一家面包店，
我知道，
然后我做了一个网球店，
包括之前的晚点等等，
就是,
我非常善于把这个事，
传起来以后，
然后就跑了，
就我就干别的了，
如果你问我说，
我干什么去了，
其实很大一个程度，
就是我，
特别不想工作，
是谁啊，
他说,
我会持续的玩一个东西，
他看起来像工作，
一旦他开始像工作，
我就跑了，
OK,
他就一下说到我心喊里了，
当然现在大家都会抱怨，
比如说，
不想上班啊，
当牛马啊，
等等,
就都能理解啊，
都能理解，
咱们也这么过来的，
我也上过班，
然后很辛苦啊，
等等,
996,
但我真的是发现，
我从小，
真的不明白，
人为什么要工作，
你想一个生物，
然后他被扔到一个星球上，
然后你跟他说，
OK,
现在有大概，
80到100年的，
这么长时间，
可活,
然后你现在得花，
这一段时间，
你的80%的时间，
来,
满足你的，
人生基本需求，
来,
吃饭,
有一个屋子遮顶，
然后,
能有点洗澡上的所，
就是,
我觉得很荒谬，
你都给我弄到这儿来了，
你干嘛让我干这个事，
你不应该让我来，
玩耍和创造，
和撒花嘛，
然后,
我从小就不知道，
这个事儿，
我跟谁说去，
当然,
我也没有因此，
就走了一个，
特别非主流路线，
我其实还是主流路线，对吧，
我自己，
认真学习，
然后上了一个，
还凑合我的大学，
然后,
进投行，
对，进投行，
反正也好像，
也在玩这个，
主流的人间那个游戏，
但始终这个东西，
对我来讲，
是,
特别特别奇怪的，
但你之前的，
前,
40年,
都干得挺好的，
所以它，
更加荒谬，
所以我才更，
脱离了，
这套体系，
否则我干得不好，
我才早脱离了，
有一个转折点吗？
可能接近三，
二十七八岁的时候，
转折点就是，
我试试不上班，
工作还要工作，
试试不上班，
不管我做自己事，
创业还是什么，
对,
然后我就再回不去了，
你看我，
我之前，
正经打工过，对吧，
后来又创业过，
然后又做过投资，
要管我基金，
还出售过企业，
还搞过小店，
还弄知识付费，对吧，
你能想象的人类的，
各种形态的工作，
较为主流的，
几种工作形式，
若干种，
我都强势我吧，
神农常白草，
对，然后你发现，
原来我是真不爱干这个事，
因为我所有时候，
我没有一个爱干的，
但是,
比如说有这种型，
对吧,
我非常爱，
这公司，
我特别愿意支持孟严，
我们做的事，
是非常有意义的，
而且我看到有这种型，
那么多用户，
客户,
因为这个服务，
产品,
公司,
改变了他们生活，
但这些跟工作没关系，
这种意思吧，
因为工作是，
上产品，
对账,
回答客服的问题，
设计新的东西，
陈鹏博士要去，
找策略，
孟严要去做管理，
你要去把很多东西，
盘起来，
这些东西我都不爱做，
所以,
说这句话，
并不是，
想说我多特殊，
或者我多什么思维，
多超钱，
更不是，
我就觉得我是一个，
经历了特别多年，
困惑我的一个人，
我就不知道自己干嘛，
然后一方面，
我就是，
不能说痛恨，
我一点儿不痛恨，
我的生活或者工作，
但我只觉得，
这有点荒谬，
然后一方面，
我干得还挺好，
或者至少不太差吧，
而且,
身边所有人，
都期待着你去工作，
对啊,
就是所有的这些，
建构起来，
加上你传统的，
东亚教育，
现在我们讲太多了，
东亚家庭，
东亚的这种范氏，
让我真正意识到，
我其实，
只想玩这件事，
是,
快四十多岁，
不知道，
这是扎实，
严谨,
细致,
承托,
然后呢，
耕耘,
所有这些词，
在我脑子中，
一个字儿，
累,
挺累的，
我就想，
我像风一样，
到处瞎吹，
到处瞎跑，
想吹到哪儿，
吹到哪儿，
但是,
我另一个层面，
我又知道，
这样是一种，
特别不负责的，
不管是对你，
做的事情不负责，
还是对自己不负责，
然后,
特别的，
我都,
所谓的，
理想主义浪漫化的，
且,
不招编辑，
不接地气的，
等等,
你可以想象，
一类的词儿，
我也都形容过自己，
或者,
我都,
反思,
反出过，
所以,
我就在这儿，
挣扎中过了，
二十年吧，
就是,
整个这套，
我自己的，
人格的特征，
我早就看见了，
当时,
我小时候就看见了，
但是,
我到了，
非常之后，
所以,
这是一个，
很长的旅程，
我记得，
我老说一个例子，
就是,
初中的时候，
大家都，
每年不写个什么，
同学录，
然后,
做幼明金句，
就是,
我初中的时候，
我就开始，
只写一句话，
就是,
王尔德的，
生活太重要，
一直不能太认真，
就是,
我明白，
其实,
我知道自己是谁了，
很小的时候，
就知道，
自己在意什么，
擅长什么，
不在意什么，
痛恨什么，
对什么东西，
莫不关心，
但是,
你要,
面对,
所有社会的，
教育,
规训,
集体意识，
自己的挣扎，
尝试,
犯错等等，
最后,
你才能，
回到,
穆辛斯说的那个，
人生是，
长途八舍的，
反普贵人，
你才能回来，
我觉得，
差不多是，
这个德性了，
你就是，
看清楚点吧，
长点心，
你就这样，
你别老觉得，
自己是那样的人，
或者说，
你可以去尝试，
但是,
你要知道，
你是在干什么，
很多时候，
我原来我不知道，
原来我以为，
我可以那样，
我可以装成那样，
我可以，
把自己变成那样，
就很痛苦，
那在过去二十年，
你岂不是，
要经历非常多的，
自我否定，
自我怀疑，
自我攻击，
对呀,
要么怎么，
一个人，
怎么才能，
个人成长，
他一定是自己，
策招心啊，
他过得天天春风得意，
他成长啥呢，
对不对，
但别人可能，
假定你是，
每天过得好像，
对,
很多人可能，
会觉得我好像这个，
我觉得，
首先肯定，
保护我的是，
底层的乐观，
就是,
我一直觉得，
我是一个很乐观的人，
就是,
我觉得，
总有方法，
一边做否定，
一边,
相信自己，
对,
相信,
反正怎么都能活，
对,
就一两周前，
我刚改了，
我的微信前面，
叫做,
没关系，
人都是要死的，
都要死的，
对,
常去来看人都会死，
对呀,
没事啊，
其实,
就死了啥，
不是了，
就你现在担忧他干嘛呢，
由于,
我觉得，
没什么事情，
值得真正的，
严肃对待，
几乎所有事，
都可以不严肃对待，
我想稍微补充一下，
我不是说，
不要去严肃对待事情，
比如说感情，
不要有一种，
好像这个事，
就是天大的事情，
然后他一旦成，
或不成，
就你人生的从此，
就,
再也不同不一样，
他就一个天大，
就是我，
我很讨厌这种东西，
或者我不习惯，
这种叙事吧，
所以有这层保护，
我就觉得，
总之,
你搞得再砸，
任何事情搞砸，
天都不会塌下来，
对,
除非你就是，
比如说，
你就给自己弄死了，
久假期肯定不行，
对吧,
就是你给自己撞死了，
那就重开吧，
对对,
重开了，
不是这个层面的事情，
我觉得也没什么，
所以在这个最底层，
我是有安全感的，
但在上面，
肯定是有很多你，
挣扎否定，
自我抨击，
然后,
不同人格的，
互相的互斥，
等等,
可能都是有这种，
而且每个人都有，
但是如荣格所说，
有一部分人，
如果比较幸运，
他在中年之后，
他会把自己的，
阴性力量，
阳性力量，
和他的黑暗人格，
和各种人格，
整合起来，
他会变成一个，
个体化的一个，
将灵魂变得完整，
同意的这么一个过程，
这就是人生，
咱们就干这个来的，
整合我们的灵魂和人格，
不断的认识自我，
对,
看到你自己不同的面向，
以及他们，
不同的面向之间，
隐含的，
共通的逻辑，
和驱动力，
就比如说，
为什么最开始问你这个问题，
因为在过去这些年，
熟悉你的朋友，
也会看到，
其实你帮助了，
很多人，
和机构，
不管是玩电，
有之有形，
然后包括你刚才说的，
面包店，
再比如说，
像一些，
很知名的，
网球运动员，
陈静菲也算吧，
算,
对,
就是你帮助和，
成就了很多人，
但是我其实那些，
一直有疑问，
我不知道你过得好不好，
挺好的，
真的吗，
还不错，
还不错的意思，
不是说，
我过得一番风顺，
和春风得意，
而是,
一个很壮的原则，
就是,
去帮助他人，
因为我比较爱帮助人，
就是这个，
是一个很中性的说法，
我比较爱帮助人，
所以,
年轻的时候一定会有，
这种,
靠,
牺牲自己，
和委屈自己，
来帮助别人的，
状态,
就像,
很多个，
家庭一样，
妈妈,
以牺牲自己，
不管是，
心理健康，
身体健康，
生活的可能性，
等等方式，
来帮助自己的儿子女儿，
什么一种，
我认为，
较为不健康的状态，
所有的帮助，
都是建立在我爽，
我确实觉得，
对他有用，
就是,
所以帮助的人，
是要隐去自我的，
你隐去自我，
你才能，
真正的，
跟对方去感同身受，
然后你才能，
找出最好的方法，
去帮助他，
隐去自我，
同时也要，
自己爽，
对呀,
隐去自我的，
希望的需求，
然后,
有的人，
可能是爽于，
他在这个过程中，
证明自己能，
我就不要，
对,
你帮任何人，
不求,
任何的回报，
只求自己爽，
也求啊，
也求,
就是,
对吧，就是，
把这件事，
本身,
当成我的收获，
而不是，
他带来的结果，
当了一个收获，
过程是奖励吗？
对,
这个就刚好，
Q到我想，
聊的第二个话题，
哇塞,
居然连上了，
我没对过，
没对过，
就是,
其实有一件事情，
我想问你很久了，
但是一直没有找到，
合适的，
机会,
就是最开始，
我们不是一起，
做投资低课吗？
一般都是，
一开始，
比如我跟莫言，
一起搭，
提纲,
大纲,
然后呢，
开始写，
写完了之后，
尤其是最开始的，
即将,
是交给，
肖宇来，
修改,
编辑,
就是,
你其实在，
投资低课上，
付出了非常多的，
心血和，
时间和努力，
是,
基本上我写的，
好,好,
然后当时，
我们出版的时候，
读库的，
创始人老六，
就跟我们说，
如果是两个作者的话，
他在人称上，
很容易让，
读者有魂消的，
感觉,
就是你说，
我怎么怎么样，
怎么怎么样，
但大家就会觉得说，
到底是，
A还是B,
他当时就建议说，
最好只保留一个作者名，
然后那个时候，
我们都觉得说，
这，很难，
就是,
这谁能答应，
说接受，
然后你竟然很爽快地答应了，
OK,
这个事情，
这次,
就是问我能不能做到，
我们现在自问，
我做不到，
原来你们觉得，
这是一很大的事，是吧，
对呀,
因为感觉，
那也是你的劳动成果，
为什么你可以做到，
我觉得你这问题，
问的好像都是我的托儿，
在夸我，
为什么我可以做到，
我有胸怀，
有格局，
其实也不是，
像海洋宽广，
对，像海洋宽广，
好,
我没有觉得，
因为我来这，
是为了帮助有这有情，
更好的成长，
就像我说的，
不就是应该这样，
我的目的是啥呢，
我的目的不就是这个吗，
所以,
对我来讲还挺简单的，
而且可能我就是，
也会暗爽嘛，
就是觉得，
我真有格局，
不是，不是，
我就觉得，
偷偷写这么一个东西，
然后还不错啊，
自己没事可以扎不扎不，
就是也挺好的呀，
不是特别那么需要，
不知道，
或者我只需要一小部分，
知道这个事就可以了，
比如你这样呢，
知道那情的人知道，
那够了，
对我来讲，
可是当孟严问你的时候，
你内心不会有任何的，
觉得,
好像不太公平，
我付出了努力，
然后,
要把我的名字拿掉之类的，
我会问一下，
自己是在意这件事吗，
我会想，
我在意吗，
是不是有点不对劲，
如果我觉得，
我确实在意，
我会说的，
但是我没觉得，
我特别在意，
而且我自己觉得，
我有,
我也没觉得，
写出这个东西来多厉害，
当然,
对这个书很骄傲，
然后我也很喜欢，
我们写的东西，
我觉得，
哇,
这个东西，
这是我人生作品了，
然后我这辈子，
只是这个东西，
扬名立万了，
也还好，
那期间为止，
有让你觉得是人生作品的，
东西吗？
我自己吧，
对,
把自己作为作品吧，
把自己作为作品打磨，
之前写的，
所有文章，
课程,
博客，书籍，
对你来说都不算吗？
真正的，
我自己的价值丸，
就是我做所有事情，
都是为了了解我自己，
那些东西都是手段，
这是真正的目的，
那我显然，
作品就是我自己了，
我不管是以前做的事，
写的东西，
犯的错误，
踩的坑，
失败的关系，
成功的关系，
所有的这些东西，
最终还是为了，
见我自己是谁，
我觉得这个是对我来讲，
特别特别特别重要的，
而且可能是唯一重要的，
我甚至，
限制的认为，
这是人来到世上，
唯一需要做的事，
just know yourself,。
就是知道你自己是谁，
当然,
我现在的理解，
对于什么是我，
什么是我自己这个事，
有更不一样的理解了，
但是我们在，
一个世俗的层面去讨论，
它就是这样的，
就是,
理解自己，
了解自己，
是最最最重要的，
是唯一重要的，
而你做的所有的事情，
都是在，
真正的在，
了解你自己，
和自己交互这个过程，
那些东西，
只是一个，
而对我来讲，
所以,
这也是我一直在坚持做的事，
既然他们，
很大程度上，
完成了这个东西，
我也就没什么太大遗憾了，
它如果能带来一些，
外部的结果呢，
也不错，
没有,
也不会特别，
怎么样？
我觉得这个说法，
它并不是说，
这是一个自私的人，
而是,
其实别人你也控制不了，
你也,
真正干涉不了，
他们有他们的因果，
我觉得一个人，
只要充分的了解好自己，
就是对这个事情，
最大的福报，
认识自己，
知道自己是什么样，
然后你这个时候，
你自然就会想，
干了点好事，
你知道吧，
自然会想，
干点好事，
就是你想，
你什么时候想，
干的好事，
一定是你自己，
很舒服的时候，
你的爱是，
溢出来的时候，
你才愿意，
给别人啊，
你自己都贼缺呢，
认识自己，
和,
感到被爱，
这不是两件什么？
不是，不是，
认识自己，
和爱,
因为,
当你认识到自己时候，
你其实，
就真正的接受了，
自己是谁，
你就没有那么多，
挣扎和痛苦了，
你就生活在一种，
很平静的自洽里，
而且你的喜悦是很自然的，
那这个时候，
你只想做一点事，
就是把想把你的喜悦，
让别人也尝一尝，
你刚才讲的时候，
我会感觉很奇妙，
因为几个月前，
我跟朋友聊的时候，
我就说，
我突然意识到，
我做的一切的事情，
其实都是为了，
完善自我，
就是自己是一个，
很平静的喜悦的状态，
感觉整个人，
非常的舒服，
协调,
然后就特别希望，
能够,
把这些东西传递给别人，
我也是，
尤其是这半年，
我就真的能感觉到，
就以前这话，
我是真的说不说，
这段我跟孟严聊过，
我说以前，
这些词，
我是真的说不出口，
但是,
我在,
比识比课，
感受到了，
很多的爱和善意，
就感觉自己，
真的成了一个，
通道一样，
吸收了很多，
爱和善意，
再把它，
通过节目也好，
通过线下也好，
传递出去，
就是,
节目也是一样的，
我自己做的，
得以忘情也是一样的，
我觉得，
都不是我在传递，
或者谁在传递，
而是,
爱这个事情，
自动的在我们这里发生，
小酒馆也好，
得以忘情也好，
我们能做的什么，
就是营造一个，
好的场域，
包括有这种行，
当你营造了一个好的场域，
人，天然，
本来就有的那种善意，
和,
爱,
就会,
自然的流出来，
同样你在一个，
糟糕的地方，
它恨和糟糕的一面，
就会被激发出来，
那当你在做这件事的时候，
当你在，
创造这个场域的时候，
你就成为这个场域，
一环,
然后每个人都经由你，
传递他们的能量，
那下一步就是，
怎么样流动得更顺畅，
就像你说的，
你在完善自己，
其实,
怎么样做一个更好的管道，
就是这么一件事儿呗，
对,
只听这几句，
大家要解释说，
这两人在聊什么吗？
马上就是什么，
周楚不散害了，
因为我所有不好嘛，
但是,
这个就像五年前，
我经常在那场面试一样，
是因为你真的，
体验了，
你才发现说，
原来这个东西，
居然是真的，
我觉得就是，
我做小酒馆的第五年，
我的心态转变非常非常大，
一会儿做的时候，
就完全是孤勇，
就是不知道哪里来的勇气，
就是先跟别人说，
我要干这个事儿，
但其实我心里，
一点普都没有，
然后这个事儿就开始做了，
是,
每期都很愁，
是怎么办，
因为,
我刚转行，
来做金融，
我认识的人非常少，
我都不知道，
上哪儿找选题，
然后就是硬着头皮做，
然后很羡慕那些，
大台,
厉害的台，
比如说，
得以往行，
我想说，
什么时候，
我也能做得这么大，
那我一定能听到，
很多很厉害的嘉宾，
很有名的人，
就当是真的很羡慕，
后来发现，
做得这么大了，
当你做得大了之后，
你确实是有机会，
请到一些，
非常厉害的，
是，是，是，
太多很大的人，
但是后来，
我发现，
我的听众们，
似乎并没有那么，
买账,
像我想象中的那样，
心绪若狂，
我就会再想，
这个问题在哪儿，
因为我一直在思考，
为什么大家要听，
执行小酒馆，
每周来听，
大家为的到底是什么，
我后来意识到说，
其实小酒馆，
是一个，
大家的小酒馆，
我们不是，
访谈很多，
名流精英的，
一个播客，
我们本来关注的，
就是普通人的，
投资理财需求，
普通人的生活，
我不应该去，
跟别人比拼，
加拼资源，
我更应该去听，
我们普通听众，
普通用户的声音，
他们过得好不好，
以及我非常非常反感，
很多的，
不管是自媒体也好，
还是说，
一部分播客也好，
他，来来回讲的，
都是一二线城市的事情，
更更大多数，
生活在中国，
其他县城市，
或者是小县城的人，
他们的生活，
他们的声音，
他们对于家庭财富，
个人,
经济状况，
到底有什么苦闹，
好像没有人去聆听，
所以从，
三四个月前，
我们就增加了一个新的栏目，
就叫做，
小酒馆故事会，
我们会用问卷，
来争取大家的一些故事，
然后远程的访谈，
比如说有大脸的，
有云难的，
有来自安徽的，
等等各个省份的，
朋友,
其实我最开始，
还有点忐忑，
会不会大家觉得这些，
因为我们第一个话题，
是我人生中的，
第一个十万，
因为我特别讨厌，
网上把，
十万不当钱，
一百万不当钱，
我希望能够，
让大家分享一下，
自己最真实的人生，
刚长到，
第一个十万的时候，
那个状态，
然后那一期，
就非常的受欢迎，
后来我发现，
这个栏目，
变成了小酒馆，
最受欢迎的栏目，
大家就非常，
愿意,
听到,
和分享，
自己的故事，
就是,
大家很愿意，
看到普通人的故事，
也很愿意，
分享自己的生活，
这个是我之前，
我现在没有预想到的，
而且包括过去半年，
我走了，
非常多的，
二三线城市，
去跟,
听有,
去面对面，
然后组织活动，
这些活动，
其实带给了我，
很多的力量，
当然,
我觉得特别好，
其实,
能感受到，
你,
整个的一个，
心路,
立成的变化，
试着,
把这个事，
再往前推一步，
就当我们再说，
可能我们不去，
比拼嘉宾资源，
和,
我们要听，
普通人的故事时候，
其实这里，
还是有一些分别的，
是,
对吧,
我们完全可以，
连这个分别都拿掉，
就也没有普通人，
和,
所谓的，
名人,
名流,
就是,
他是不是，
现在,
做我们的嘉宾，
我们有一个，
很好的，
很真实，
真诚的交流，
至于,
也不是很重要，
我们就是，
把这个人，
请过来，
跟我们一起，
创造一些东西，
就完了，
你就想，
这个节目，
可能一百年后，
也有人听，
那会儿，
还谁知道，
你请的嘉宾是谁，
但你,
一期节目里的，
真心,
很真诚的，
在当下的，
对话,
的那个感受，
感觉,
那传达出的，
能量是，
永远不会变的，
其实把这个做好，
就够了，
因为,
你以为，
大家听，
我的节目，
或者你的节目，
你的节目，
maybe,
还有一些，
获取知识的部分，
过,
三年五年十年，
一定不是什么，
知识改变了你，
但现代人，
最确的就是真心，
为什么，
其实每个人，
都有真心，
只是大家，
不觉得这事重要了，
或者说，
这个事被打击了，
但是,
越在这个时刻，
真心就越宝贵，
我觉得，
真心小伙伴，
四个大字，
真的,
不是,
我觉得，
真的,
我现在，
人到中年，
就觉得真心最宝贵，
然后一定要有这个东西，
不管干什么事，
多少有这个东西，
虽然我也做不到，
时时刻刻，
每件事都有，
但,
我能有的时候，
我一定有，
因为这，
最赚的是我自己，
因为我对你，
特别真心，
我靠我，
我多高兴啊，
你懂我意思吗？
因为我才是，
最大受益者，
我们只有在，
给予的时候，
才能证明自己有啊，
什么呀？
因为你只能追寻，
你没有的东西，
所以你越追寻幸福，
你越没有幸福啊，
因为追寻证明了，
你没有啊，
所以我尽量给出，
我少追寻，
就这么简单，
做节目也是一样的，
所以你很少会感受到，
区法感吗？
或者不安全感？
经常有，
不需要想象一种状态，
好像达到了某种境界，
然后你就没有什么，
这些负面情绪或者区法，
都会有的，
因为这就是人，
这具身体在世间行走，
你就是要经历这些事情，
你就是时时刻刻，
人性就会突然提醒你，
我靠,
那人长得比你帅，
那人比你瘦，
那人比你有钱，
就是这是很自然那种情绪，
但,
核心的逻辑是你要，
识别出它，
然后跟它相处，
然后不去压抑它，
也不去鼓励它，
去练习这么一种，
跟它相处的东西，
而不是说你就没有这些东西了，
不可能没有的。
不是,
这个跟匱乏感，
不太一样，
你说这个好像是一点，
轻微的，
比较之后带来的不爽，
但是匱乏感是，
比如有些人就觉得，
赚了钱永远不够，
没有安全感，
或者永远不敢停下来，
觉得自己必须得从，
一个工作，
听到另外一个工作，
中间不可以休息，
在情绪关系里，
有些人也是这样。
我理解，
就是匱乏，
匱乏的核心还是，
不够嘛，
不够,
就是你觉得你自己是incomplete，
就是你，
你是不完整的，
你缺一点东西，
然后你觉得你有那个东西，
你更完整，
或者你就可以完整了，
OK?
这个是，
不论大小，
你刚才说的很大的事，
还我小的事，
这个是人的基本设置，
我们的基因设定，
就是这样的，
就是你要在生活中，
寻找,
你缺的东西，
否则的话，
你就难受。
当你没有欲望的时候，
你有感觉，
就是人为什么总在，
追求很多东西，
很多人说，
贪欲,
或者你的什么，
什么家庭教育，
人,
原生家庭，
什么,
其实核心是，
当你不去追求这些东西的时候，
你会感受到死亡，
接近于死本身，
因为,
我们是靠什么维持自己，
是活着的一种想象，
就是,
我们不断的要去追求一些东西，
这样的话，
你就脑中有不断有念头，
不断有想法说，
我要这个，
我要那个，
我有这个动力，
然后我可以追求这个东西，
然后我可以拿到那个东西，
来补足我的不同，
等等,
在这个过程中，
你才有生，
你才觉得，
人才会觉得，
这是生的表现，
这是离离，
这是生活，
这是生命的表现，
所以,
刚才你说一句话，
我没有去纠正你，
你说你不断的在完善自己，
我可以告诉你，
什么东西可完善，
因为,
当你去完善的时候，
你就永远没法完善自己，
是谁告诉你需要完善呢，
是谁告诉你你不够的，
是同一个人，
是同一个声音告诉你不够，
同时那个声音又告诉你，
你要去完善，
但你当你把这些声音拿掉的时候，
你,
你就是完整了，
你就是幸福本身，
我,
这一两年在练习一个东西，
然后练得也不是特别好，
但我觉得，
还是有点进步的，
叫做无我的行动，
什么意思，
就是在整个过程中，
只有选择而没有选择者，
比如说，
你睡觉，
第二天明天早上起来了，
你刚醒的那一刻，
你是没有什么我的意识的，
但是你仍然可以去，
哎,
明明呼呼去刷牙，
然后,
做饭,
然后可能，
看一眼手机，
对,
身体它会有一个倾向，
你的情绪，
你的身体会带你走，
然后,
等到一个时间点，
你会冒出一个念头，
叫做我今天干了这些事，
它声称了，
所有这些行为的，
负责者，
它变成这个东西的发起者，
和执行者，
控制者，
和享受者，
但实际上这个我，
是仅存在那个念头本身的，
如果你没有这个念头，
其实没有一个真正的我，
在干一些事，
那我反过来说，
这有什么意义啊，
当我们有一个我的意识的时候，
你会发现，
我们会出于很多，
错误的，
原因去做事情，
比如说，
今天你录了一个播客，
然后搞砸了，
OK?
这里边有，
三个层面的事情在发生，
第一个层面，
事件层，
这个播客录砸了，
OK?
第二个层面，
叫做情绪层，
情绪层，
你可能感受到，
傲毁,
痛苦,
失望,
自责,
反正一系列的，
这是一个层面，
第三层，
叙事层，
就是,
我以后再也不能，
请这种嘉宾了，
我,
下次一定要注意，
不能这么干，
我是不是不适合干这个事，
或者,
这个,
我是不是现在对这个工作，
有点疲惫了，
就是,
任何一个事情的发生，
其实都有三个层面的东西，
但是我们大多数人，
活在叙事里的，
就是,
你会,
为这个事情，
添加很多，
不必要的，
我的成分在里面，
这就导致，
你无法真正的，
看见这个事情的本身，
因为,
这个事情可能，
就是一个，
各种原因造成的，
一个事情，
它没有那么完美，
当我们，
认知到这个事，
如果我们没有那种，
啊，我不行，
我这，我那的想法，
我们可以，
很自然地，
面对这个事实，
然后我们就说，
啊,
然后这个这个，
找一个，
更耐弹的人，等等，
你会自发自动的，
有一些，
应对方式，
和你的总结出来的，
但是,
当我们增加了叙事，
它就会逐渐变成了一个，
我怎么样，我怎么样，
最后,
它会变成什么，
它会变成一个，
我们,
整体对自己的认知，
就是,
我是一个，
擅长表达的人，
不擅长写作的人，
我是一个，
细心的人，
我是一个NFP，
然后我是一个，
什么,
创业者，
他在这个心理结构，
他活在这个心理结构的层面，
然后,
这就是，
比赛的时候，
为什么，
你,
最自发自动的时候，
你打的球是最好的，
当你有我进来的时候，
就不会了，
所以,
从这个角度讲，
我说的无我的行动，
是什么，
就是,
我不再希望，
我以某种身份，
为出发来做事情，
比如说，
我是一个，
特别有独到见解的人，
所以我要，
做一件事，
要证明我是这个身份，
我是一个播客，
这些特别不一样的人，
然后,
我拿出来的播客，
就得,
怎么怎么样，
然后,
或者一个事，
我当我搞砸了，
我就觉得，
这个失败，
是我全权负责的我，
我是一个特别糟糕的，
或者我是一个特别，
不擅长做这个事的人，
就是在整个过程中，
当我,
其实,
本质上是一个，
心理结构的时候，
你去掉我，
反而能够，
更接近，
这个事情的真相，
然后,
再加一个东西，
现在很多人说活在当下，
几乎很少有人，
真正能说清楚，
活在大什么意思，
我有一个特别简单的解释，
也不是，
标准答案，
但,
可以听听这个解释，
就是,
你是活在这个体验本身里，
还是活在这个体验的解释里，
或者对这个体验的想法里，
比如说我们看一个日落，
你在看日落的时候，
你是最幸福的，
因为你脑子里，
没有任何垫头，
什么时候我会跳出来呢？
你下一秒就说，
我今天看了一场日落，
它特别好，
这个时候，
我就成为了一个，
蓄势的中心，
然后大部分的时候，
我们在做一件事的时候，
是停留在，
你没有在那体验日落，
而是在体验，
我体验日落这个事，
我们在想法那层去活着，
当你有这个想法的时候，
你就没在当下了，
因为你体验的，
不是这个事本身了，
而是体验对这个事的认知，
我觉得这是特别可惜的一点事，
我们很多时候，
就直接跳过体验本身，
而去体验，
我们对这个体验的，
各种的comment，
这个评论，
认知想法等等，
最后就导致，
其实,
我就觉得我半辈子白活了，
因为我都没有体验那个事，
我在体验我自己在这个事里，
然后我就，
会把,
所有的东西，
归结于，
我是怎么样的，
于是我，
因为是这样的，
所以我要这样去，
最后你发现，
我就在所有的这个情况里，
我都会感觉到，
愧罚和恐惧，
因为愧罚和恐惧本身，
正是,
念头本身，
就是你的恐惧存在于你的念头里，
它不是一个具体的东西，
你不存在事件层，
对,
事件层是没有恐惧的，
只有你对它的解读才有恐惧，
所以我觉得我的愧罚和恐惧，
就有点说回来，
它是,
绕得点远，
但是我想说的是，
就是我发现，
其实我作为一个，
脑子比较好使的人，
我体验生活，
本身的东西，
或者体验生活本身的这个，
能力是很差的，
因为我一直在加弹幕，
因为你解释能力太强，
解释能力太强，
你永远在解释各种事情，
我一直在这个层面里，
我就遮蔽了，
我跟这个体验本身的东西，
然后还有一层遮蔽是什么，
是对情绪的遮蔽，
就是那天我写了一个微博说，
我自己一个比较大的教训是，
我会有一个习惯性的动作，
就是当情绪出现的时候，
我喜欢去分析它，
用分析替代感受，
就是一个事出现了，
哎,
我很痛苦，
我很恐惧，
为什么我会痛苦，
我很糟心，
或者为什么这事带来痛苦，
我怎么严重是要方法论来，
规避这个东西，
或者我为什么会产生这个东西，
就是很多人，
很多人包括我，
都非常习惯于，
面对情绪的时候，
两种方法，
一种是 avoid，
就是直接压抑它，
按住了，
或者就是 analyze，
分析它，
就是我发现，
我为了逃避情绪，
干了特别得得得的事，
因为我其实是一个，
感受力非常强的人，
就再次生命，
这不是一个自我的夸奖，
是一个，
某种程度还是困扰我很久的事情，
就是我为了不体验，
一些我讨厌的情绪，
我干了太多的事了，
当然我学心理学，
我搞灵性，
我什么弄玄学，
然后我学八字，
然后搞星盘，
反正就是，
然后了解自己，
等等等等，
你再这样研究下去，
就周楚出三汉了，
周楚出三汉，对对对，
就是我所有的东西都搞一遍，
当然首先我肯定有些靠地心，
然后我觉得这些东西很有意思，
了解自己是很有意思，
但是我觉得这里面，
包括我可能，
一不舒服了，
我可能去打个球，
对吧,
或者我可能最简单的，
刷手机，
或者我点个外卖，
就是,
花很多很多的时间，
逃避这个情绪，
都是为了不去体验它，
然后现在很多人讲什么修行，
讲什么搞玄学，
其实也一样，
在我看来，
都是自欺欺人，
因为我自欺欺人过来的，
不是,
现在很多人说疗愈，
我现在明白，
疗愈就是最大的骗局，
为什么呢？
对啊,
疗愈是非常大的骗局，
但是我这说法有点极端，
我听我讲完，
因为,
当你疗愈这个事的时候，
大多数人，
会认为，
他在做一个交易，
就是,
我只要去疗愈他，
我就可以不体验他了，
由于我特别害怕体验这个，
埋藏我身处的痛苦，
所以我要找一个方法，
他治好，
这样我就不去体验他了，
就比如说，
像你前面说的，
一个不好的，
逃避情绪的方式是分析他，
可是,
我觉得我个人的经历和体验是，
他会让我更好的跟情绪相处，
我觉得他肯定有他的意义，
肯定有他能帮助你更好的交易相处，
或者说这么说，
你会不会，
充分的体验他以后再去分析，
还是你，
那个东西一起来你就去分析了？
很难,
很难分辨，
你下次可以观察一下，
我觉得至少我从我，
我自己和我观察的很多人来讲，
大部分时候，
大家去做这些动作，
都是不想去体验，
但是,
这也是非常大的问题，
因为他是一种更高级的逃避和，
更高级的压抑，
他有一天会以别的方式，
回来的，
而且回来的会更猛，
而且回来的会，
让你发现你根本就是，
一直在自己欺人，
我之前想露西伯克，
就特别简单，
叫做feel the feeling,。
现在人不会feel feelings，
就不会感受感受，
我以前就是这样，
就会回啊，
就是,
这是特热，
你碰一下，
可能我刚感受一点，
我马上去跳去分析，
我刚感受一点，
我赶紧马上去跳去拿手机，
刷臂站，
我可能刚感受一点，
我就去找前女友复合，
听到什么？
没有没有，
就是我举这个例子，
但是我觉得这两天，
对我帮助最大的就是，
我觉得我可以去感受这个感受，
怎么去感受，
特别简单，
就是当你有这个情绪之后，
你就找一椅子，
你坐下，
然后你就，
脑子里没有念头的，
去体验，
这个raw sensation,。
什么叫raw sensation,。
最本源的这个身体感受，
比如说，
这个情绪来的时候，
你是凶慢，
还是背紧，
还是位在翻滚，
还是头皮在发麻，
还是手指交在抖动，
然后在这个过程中，
你尽管去体验它，
并且不给它命名，
你不要把它命名成，
悲伤,
愤怒,
生气,
失望,
痛苦,
你不去命名，
你只是感受这个感受，
然后,
很大的可能性是，
特别难受，
你就跳出来了，
你就又去分析了，
或者又去干别的，
OK，没关系，
下次类似的情况再来，
你再去感受它，
然后,
你看,
这有连到另外一个话题，
现在很多人说，
接纳情绪，对吧，
什么叫接纳一个事情，
或者接纳一个情绪，
我同样给一个，
我的定义，
其实Rupiah Spira的定义，
这个我最好的老师，
什么叫接纳，
特别简单，
你不是接纳这个情绪了吗，
那你愿不愿意这个情绪，
永远伴随你余生，
那,
负月情绪还是不愿意的吗，
那就是不接纳，
或者说，对，
当你的接纳，
是打着一种旗号的，
交易的时候，
它就是假的接纳，
因为你接纳，
它是为了不接纳，
接纳是为了让它过去，
让它赶走，赶走，
那不就是假接纳吗，
你现在能带着这个事，
带着这个伤疤一直走，
而且还觉得挺好，
觉得没事，
这才是真接纳，
但我们做了很多假的接纳事，
我为，好，
你不让我接纳吗，
好，我接纳它，
它是不是能不跟着我了，
我可以不再体验它了，
就是如果你接纳了它，
别人在提起这件事情，
你不是说，
这个东西不要再聊了之类的，
而是能够坦然地去面对它，
你甚至还会有悲痛，
甚至还会有难受，
但是你就是，
接纳的事情我就发现，
我甚至有时候是故意去想一想它，
诶，完位一下，
我这个体验，
然后我还是痛，
我还是难受，
但是我可以接受它，
余生都跟我这么搞，
你好变态哦，
练习嘛，
不是，因为这个是，
让你去接近自由的一种东西，
因为其他的东西都被你压抑了，
天天分析着弄大的，
然后,
整天搞的挺那什么，
最后发现我都是在骗我自己，
我不去感受它，
就是让我想到，
我今年其实，
经历了一段特别糟糕的感情经验，
OK,
太合适了，
终于到他们正题了，
就是,
我现在回想起来，
确实就像你说的，
确实是很快就跳到了分析的部分，
然后呢，
我的反应也非常的得体，
当时我就觉得非常奇妙，
就那个时候，
我感觉我像是个第三者在观察自己，
我是一个使喻，
从小到大都特别好，
新冠的时候都不影响我，
对，不影响我十一的人，
但是那几天我真的吃不下东西，
我就觉得哇好神奇啊，
就是神奇跟我的理智，
它是可以分开的，
是的,
然后,
确实后面，
过了几个月，
就是我以为这事早就过去了，
我都可以跟朋友开玩笑，
开玩笑风声啊，
对,
然后因为一些特殊的原因，
就是会恐慌发作，
你这就是你压抑的那种东西吗？
你存在那儿了，
没处理它，
你最后拍那台，
就会来的，
我觉得现在回头看，
它对我来说，
是挺珍贵的一段经历的，
包括当时，
当我恐慌发作的时候，
特别好笑，
因为那时候我在外地嘛，
我当时求助了三个朋友，
得到了反馈，
让我更加崩溃，
然后我发现我就没招了，
我就只能去感受这个情绪，
和他相处，
让自己慢慢的呼吸平稳下来，
让自己手脚不要那么发凉，
然后去出去吃饭，
回到路上，
当时我路过一条花街，
专门卖花的一条街，
然后我突然有一点点想通了，
就感心里的重量，
变轻了很多，
就是我意识到，
就是这个事情发生在我身上，
它其实和，
楼上突然掉了花盆砸你头，
让你差不多，
就是可能你确实也没做错任何事情，
可能就是纯倒霉，
就发生了就发生了，
OK，过去就好，
你觉得它有必然性吗？
我觉得有，
不可能没有的，
对，对吧，
我觉得，
就是它和我内在的某一种区法感，
它还是相关的，
就是我觉得，
我以为我不是，
但其实，
可能在某种程度上，
在我心里一个很深的角落，
我还是觉得，
我应该，
找到另外一个人，
让我可能生活变得更幸福，
OK，更完整，
对,
你过去的几任，
前男友或者亲密关系，
你觉得有共性吗？
我说,
你们相处模式他们的，
风格或者等等？
我觉得，
没有太大的共性，
但是我在亲密关系里，
的表现是有很大的共性的，
比如说，
比如说就是，
我发现我对于亲密关系里的人，
其实包括我对我父母，
有时候也会，
容易不耐烦，
OK,
嗯,
他跟你，
就上一期录的播客有点相似，
就是很容易，
大脑会自动的去，
揣测别人在想什么，
以及预判，
对方的想法和行为，
然后自己再来，
生成一套分析，
就是永远在预判对方的预判，
OK,
嗯,
所以导致，
很累,
会,
就是比如说，
我会再想说，
如果比如说我提出了这个，
建议A,
他可能会怎么怎么想，
那么他会怎么怎么说，
如果建议B，
他会怎么怎么说，
我大脑会自动的，
有意识的去会运转，
这样的一套系统，
然后一旦，
出了一些意外事情的时候，
那我大脑就会转得更快了，
然后他可能CPU就烧了，
嗯,
我以前可能没有太意识到这件事情，
但是现在会是，
然后我就会，
显得非常的骄傲，
然后呢，
对方就看到我在按打住自己的骄傲，
假装很冷静，
但是其实别人都看得出来，
我并不冷静的在，
表达,
或者是在行事，
嗯,
那你觉得你，
你为什么会有这套自动系统，
你可以追溯到什么时候，
那当然，
一切,
问题都是原生家庭的错，
原生家庭，
是这样的呀，
OK,
所以你看，
你已经说出来了，
就是说，
其实这一套，
跟,
他人,
尤其是较为亲密的人的，
模式,
其实是，
复制了你跟你，
家庭的，
这种,
应对的方式，
嗯,
这就是，
你要,
破的东西，
就是我，
几个月前发明那个词吧，
不是什么高级词，
叫做,
命运杀猪盘，
命运杀猪盘就是什么，
这点像桌友，
就是,
命运杀猪盘，
就是说，
你没有踩过大坑，
不是因为你多高明，
不是因为我多厉害，
是因为还没有给我，
特别定制那一款，
专为我，
设计的杀猪盘来找我，
一旦来找我，
我爹的比谁都快，
然后我也经历了，
就是,
每一个人在生活中，
在社会的规讯中，
你说的教育，
你的基因，
你的原生家庭，
等等一系列，
最后会形成一套，
体系套模式，
然后这个模式，
一定在某种特定的情况下，
贼吃亏，
如果你足够幸运的话，
你一定会遇到这个坑，
因为这个坑就是来帮你，
破这个模式的，
来度我呢，
来度你呢，
就是命运杀猪盘，
没遇到的时候都觉得，
他怎么会，
因为这种事被骗，
或者他怎么会，
被这种事所蒙蔽双眼？
对，这就是我当时的，
完全是我感受，
我想说，
我每天，
装的贼理智，
特别的清醒，
结果居然，
会因为这种事情，
恐慌发作，
这怎么会是我？
这就是人，
所以,
一样的嘛，
就像你说的，
你可能，
外界看我，
你看我，
就是,
我挺好，
挺自洽，
挺自在，
然后,
特质感情，
我的意思是，
你越稳固的，
一套价值体气，
遇到能，
破破你的人，
合适,
那一定死得更惨，
就是,
你一定有你的，
命运杀猪盘，
今年已经遭遇过了，
对，你遭遇过了，
你就,
福报啊，
真是福报，
因为,
你过了这个，
你就破了，
当然,
你可能，
一次没破完，
命运会持续给你，
一样的，
不是,
命运会给你，
持续一样的问题，
直到你给出，
next time,。
你不这样了，
你就真的，
向自由靠近了一步，
这就是福报，
真是福报，
你只要破了这个模式，
你就是一个新人了，
对我来讲是这样了，
我来分享一点我的，
就省得你，
对吧，老说你，
我的模式特别简单，
我的模式就是说，
我对我重视的关系，
经常有极其不健康的期待，
并且,
我会化身一个巨大的天狗，
对,
是的，你看，
所有人听到这个都是，
听到这个，
问题那儿，
怎么可能，对吧？
听到最后因我惊有，
听到最后，
基本上是崩了掉，
因为是这样的，
就是,
我后来明白了，
我是一个特别特别在意，
关系的人，
然后我非常渴望有，
怎么说，
灵魂层面的，
这种沟通和交流的关系，
你的杀猪盘就在这了，
对，有的时候，
它是友谊，
有的时候，
它是亲密关系女朋友，
对吧，有的时候，
有各种形式嘛，
需要这个东西，
灵魂之交融，
那这个时候，
每当我遇到一些人的时候，
他可能会出现两种情况，
一种情况是，
这人跟我确实很聊的，
但他也没有到那种灵魂的地步，
然后我就会骗自己，
说我们俩是这样的，
所以每当他，
做不到这样的时候，
我就对他很失望，
嗯,
然后你就想离开他，
我不想离开他，
我就教他，
你他改造他，
不是改造，
改造就有点傲慢了，
我还没那么傲慢，
我就教他，
我跟他说，
你看,
我是这么理解的，
你看你那么理解，
理解我，
我跟你说明书，
我之前在，
更早一起过会，
也提过这个事，
就是,
我希望对方，
我的那种渴望，
病态的渴望，
会导致我，
就是说，
OK,
打引号的，
把它当成AI，
然后把我所有数据费的给他，
喂给他，
然后希望他能，
创造出一个，
极其理解我的一个模板，
出来,
如果他做不到，
我就最后就，
就非常非常不亏，
他有极大的耐心，
配合我，
做一切这样的事，
但是,
由于我自己，
一直在变化，
我都搞不清楚，
我自己在干嘛，
对方就跟不上我了，
这跟不上，
不是说我成长多快点，
跟不上，
而是,
我总在变化，
然后最后，
对方都不知道，
两月就，
没有新课题了，
所以他就累了，
他也就走了，
然后我非常需要，
我在对方那，
是特别特殊的，
这个特殊，
已经变态到，
咱这节目，
没事,
没事，没事，没事，
就是,
没有什么不好的，
只是我觉得，
自我暴露有点多，
可能不是，
所有人都想听这个，
但无所谓，
就是,
我觉得这个病态，
就是在于，
我都甚至希望，
对方以，
我不能理解，
我自己的方式，
来理解我，
就他要看到，
我看不到，
我自己的东西，
现在发现，
只有GPT能做到，
当天还没有GPT，
对吧,
然后我非常需要，
我对他是特殊的，
就是,
我经常说一句话，
我不用是你的，
什么什么，
永远第一个想起的人，
不用,
但我需要我在里面，
特别特别特殊的，
至于怎么特殊，
我都不知道，
然后我就觉得，
很奇怪，
就是说，
为什么会有人，
对一个，
另外一个人，
提出这样的要求呢，
然后,
对方知道这回事吗？
知道,
因为,
可能一个友谊，
或者一个清明外，
走到一定阶段的时候，
我就会，
提出这个事，
我就告诉到，
我是这样的人，
可能也有点期待，
他斥我为这样吧，
那这个时候，
就会变成一种，
然后我就，
顾不得，
真正跟他去互动了，
因为我，
每一个互动，
我都活在，
我是特殊的吗？
我对他是不是不一样，
等等,
我就没有再体验，
这个关系本身了，
我就在，
整天关注这些，
破玩意儿，
最后导致，
永远不可能，
别人,
每次都满足你的期待的，
然后,
这个关系就无法成立，
所以我因此，
失去过，
对我分化重要的人，
我后来才发现，
这种,
病态吧，
就是,
有一种，
灵魂的区法，
你老觉得好像需要，
有一些外界的东西，
来弥补你灵魂的这种，
老觉得自己缺点什么，
我现在终于明白了，
就是,
这外边，
没有任何东西，
能补缺我这个，
灵魂的缺法的，
因为他不是，
这个层面的事，
他是在更高层面，
你解决的，
但我现在，
也先不说这个话题，
所以现在，
我就,
一下,
破了这个模式了，
就是,
在一次最惨烈的崩溃中，
一定是在一个跟，
你最后一次发现，
这样真的，
就,
就崩了，
然后你就，
难以为继了，
真的不能再这样了，
痛定思痛，
然后想，
这一切到底究竟为了什么，
最后走到这儿了，
可能一两年时间，
甚至更久，
所以现在，
病情稳定了吗？
病情几稳定，
就是,
破了这个模式的，
破了这个模式，
不是走向反线，
我就不要求这种，
而是,
更淡然地去看这些事情，
这种,
奇怪的要求了，
然后,
反而能更真实，
这关系本身，
不管它是什么样子的，
特殊不特殊，
其实都不重要，
我只是在当下去体验，
跟这个人，
或者跟这些人，
那一种很真实的，
我们之间的，
关系互动表达，
不用太多地去，
解释,
产视和评论，
和分析它，
只是体验关系本身，
体验我们的流动本身，
体验我们中间的，
情感本身，
不用老问，
这是哪样，
那是哪样，
咱俩怎么样，
好不好，
然后,
咱俩的确认，
它很,
苍白啊，
就很苍白，
但你没安全感的时候，
你不就想要这个吗？
你没安全感的时候，
不天天问你，
还不爱我吗？
就我只举个例子，
就很难想到，
你居然也是个
没有安全感的人，
当然没有，
而且我自己又特别，
我表敏锐，
然后我也能很容易，
动差别人的人心，
所以我，
舔起来很厉害的，
高级舔狗，
可不是给你买点，
早餐那种，
就是,
like,
我会在各个层面上，
把对这个人的关心，
关注，关爱，
做的任务习惑生，
就是最高级的舔，
是让他感觉不到自己被舔，
因为这样他压力最小，
那他怎么知道是，
他不需要特别的知道，
这就是我的戏啊，
就我自己，
跟我自己演啊，
真的是这样，
你想,
刚才我们说到了吗？
我一个，
什么作者，
可以不署名，
对我来讲根本不是事，
所以类似的情境对我都无所谓，
你都不需要知道是我干的，
那到最后不就是，
有一种爱叫做放手吗？
对啊，就只能放手，
因为太累了，
你知道吧，
对,
我回忆起一些事，
确实是不能讲，
不是,
因为讲一下就会知道是谁，
很容易知道是谁，
然后,
属性的听众可能就是，
对对对，我想说，
对,
大型做暴露啊，
反正,
都是普通人，
我也是，
第一次做，
是吧,
那就对了，
因为我平时都看起来，
非常正常的在工作，
那,
一般这种人是最不正常的，
真的,
就是我原来那段感情，
真的会让我觉得很不可思议，
就是我，
之前一直没有意识到说，
原来,
我以为自己已经各方面挺好了，
但其实我内心某个角落，
居然还是希望，
一个,
完美的，
对,
就是灵魂伴侣之类的，
就是我居然会对这个东西，
有这么大的，
我们在，
彻底放弃一个事情之前，
都是要分离一跃，
最后再抓一下，
就是这样的，
一定要，
让你死心啊，
这样堵塗，
最后,
最后搞一把大的，
我也是这样的，
一样的，
我不甘心的时候，
你就是不甘心，
99%的甘心是最可怕的，
因为1%的不甘心，
会创造出，
1千的毁灭性，
因为你最后搞一个大的，
然后你就灭灭了，
一个核弹和平了，
一切都归于寂静，
但如果你不面对这个破碎，
你在废墟上建立不下来东西的，
为什么中年人有这么多痛苦啊，
中年危机，
是因为他的baggage，
就是他的包袱，
我都很难用中文形容，
就是你历史上，
累积的那个情绪的那个，
大的节点，
全被压抑了，
然后你压到有一天，
压不住了，
然后你中年全爆发了，
然后你就自毁啊，
因为你无力去处理，
累积的这些东西，
你才危机嘛，
然后你，
危机你怎么解决，
没什么力量解决，
你只能，
寻求一种奇怪的外力，
来解决，
这就是人，
人就是在，
漫长的岁月中，
积累了很多东西，
没有被释放掉，
没有被处理，
然后每次都应激一遍，
每次都重复一遍，
命运杀出盘，
就是,
荣哥有个词叫，
FATOM,
他说的啥，
他说的就是，
因为你就破不了这个模式，
你就一直在这儿绕，
绕绕绕绕，绕十遍，
然后有的人要一辈子过去了，
我们就要，
破的就是这个东西，
那从什么开始，
就从真正的接纳你的情绪，
和处理你的，
感受开始，
然后别去绕过它，
来的时候你就接一下，
来的时候你就碰一下，
还有就是，
要花时间做这点事，
千万别把自己变成一个，
明明心里有一个巨大的洞，
然后你还假装没事人，
就是这样非常累，
而且,
一定会一些奇怪的模式，
爆发的，
我在想，
其实对于非常多的人，
我觉得在人群中，
可能是绝大多数，
第一是很难，
可能在这么多年的，
教育,
或者是社会文化的规讯下，
第一是很难感受到自己的情绪，
第二是，
他也不知道该怎么样去，
发泄这个情绪，
还能怎么办呢？
对,
这就是我觉得，
很多人缺失的东西，
包括我自己，
我觉得我肯定是，
感受能力还是比较强的，
但是我仍然在，
很长时间，
你不知道怎么去处理它，
当然我也试了很多方法，
就像我说的，
我学心理学，
然后读书，
然后什么什么冥想，
反正都干了，
现在我就更清晰，
我在干什么了，
所以我就还是，
本质上，
真的是鼓励大家，
去面对这些东西，
然后去，
理解这件事很重要，
就是,
这件事，
原比,
你找一个什么好工作，
完成一个什么事情，
或者什么什么什么，
取一个什么样的老婆，
嫁一个什么样的老公，
比这些东西都重要的多，
我不说那些东西不重要，
而是当你没有这个东西的时候，
你后面那些事，
都将是，
一种,
注定了不怎么样的东西，
你解决了这个，
你刚才说的那些，
所有的事业，
关系，感情，
生活,
都会随之改变的，
你接受自己的光明和黑，
你就是一个更健全的人，
健全的人干的事，
本身就是有生命力的，
所以我觉得，
就是健全健康的，
就是这个时代，
有健全人吗？
咱别,
就是你先，
也不管别人，
对呀，管好自己，
管好自己，
还是回到跟他说，
你管好自己，
就是最大的福报，
因为只要有一个健全人，
这个人们就会相信，
世界上可以有健全人，
就会不一样，
就像你说的，
看到了，
你就相信了，
你永远不相信了，
这个世界，
就是有健全人的，
真的有，
或者,
是有把健全自己，
作为人生最重要的事的人的，
作为人生的第一优先级的人的，
那你又说过，
不全自己，
不对了，
就是我们在社会层面，
或者在这个世间，
这个层面，
肯定是要去，
做人格的发展和整合的，
但是,
如果你用另一套话语体系，
那,
因为这些还是故事，
因为还有桑曼吐闭整合的，
对,
就是我说的，
晚上自己有稍微解释，
就是,
是因为，
比如说在过去几年，
我能感受到自己，
比如说，
越来越接受自己，
更喜欢自己，
不管是情绪变得更稳定，
还是说，
认知层面的提升，
确实是有一种，
自己在不断晚上的感觉，
这是为什么我会说，
我会感觉是这样的，
所以一般就，
越这会儿都要崩嘛，
给你来一个大的，
是告诉你，
什么晚上，
别在这儿，
是直接给你献主啊，
直接给你献主，
对，这就是命运的有趣之处，
因为这才是终极的晚上，
还可以继续体会，
杀入团还在不远的，
将来等着我，
新的杀入团，
绝对还会有，
但是你会发现，
你真的能识别出来，
慢慢你会真的识别出来，
我现在就有这种感觉，
比以前识别能力提高很多，
我不敢说，
晚上了，
但是就是，
这个又是来搞我的，
就是,
这个以前的我肯定会掉进去啊，
现在我，
还是有点想掉进去，
但是我稍微想一想，
就有很多这种时刻，
我一定知道这个世界上，
有命运来搞我了，
那我以后再掉进去，
我就更快能出来，
就也就挺好的嘛，
我可以问一个，
稍微细腻一点的问题吗？
就是前面你说，
你其实讨厌严肃的东西，
讨厌非常实操，
落地很瑣碎，
尤其是很严谨的一些东西，
那这个对于，
你做投资不会，
很拉你的后腿吗？
会啊,
所以我经常亏钱都是因为这个，
啊这样吗？
对,
我主要是大判断做的好了，
我都会赚钱，
然后我需要一些更细节的计算，
和,
规划,
和记录，
和那什么的话，
我都亏很多，
所以最后我就不投资了，
我说的不投资，
不是说那种不投资的，
我就是以完全我自己能，
理解的方式去投资，
对,
就是,
所以你现在是，
我现在是什么，
我现在就，
休息啊，
歇着,
对,
就是这样，
就是我不想再做那些，
特别具体的事情，
然后我就，
以后的职业就一个字玩，
玩肯定很重要，
呃,
我觉得很，
很简单，
以后就，
无我的行动啊，
就是我不想，
我要达成什么，
我要干什么，
没有，反正就是，
不做任何计划，
对，生命会自然带着我走吧，
在哪吃哪呗，
感觉就是一个，
很奇妙的状态，
嗯,
我也在体会，
我觉得是挺奇妙的，
所以,
可以这么理解吗，
当时,
比如说孟严也好，
有周有行也好，
都是,
在那个阶段，
刚好,
大家彼此结怨，
嗯,
当然,
我觉得很简单，
就是,
我在这整个这个事情的发生中，
我,
我去做，
我能起到做的部分就完了，
对吧,
就是,
我一本书，
我就爱写开头，
我就写十个开头，
我觉得也挺好，
生活哪有什么一定之归，
无所谓啊，
对啊,
所以就，
挺开心的啊，
嗯,
这不五年了也来路了嘛，
对吧,
是啊,
哎,
因为我这段是想了一个，
我其实我有个问题，
不是有一个问题，
但是我感觉，
这个问题，
也不太对，
就是我想问，
为什么，
抛弃了价值投资，
但是我又想了一下，
你好像也没有，
我从来不是什么价值投资者，
嗯,
或者说，
我都不知道什么叫价值投资，
OK,
不是,
首先我就觉得，
我没有觉得我是一个，
多么,
正经投资者，
这是我的，
完了,
这课卖不出去了，
野门已经卖很多了，
就是,
我肯定，
理解,
和知道，
适合,
很多人，
大众的，
所谓的，
正确的投资方式是什么，
并且我也能把它讲得很清楚，
嗯,
我是一个还不错的，
老师,
或者传播的人，
翻译家，
翻译者，
但我自己的个性，
就是不想搞这些东西，
所以我也不知道，
我是一个什么投资者，
我觉得，
我自己，
更想成为一个，
在金钱上有，
真正安全感的人，
所以,
我更多的功夫，
下在这个层面上，
而不是，
投资层面，
对,
比如说，
什么是有金钱上的安全感，
就是,
可能一个标准，
我自己瞎说的，
你不需要，
总,
赚到钱，
你才,
觉得舒服，
啊?
我试着去，
切换一种模式，
就是,
我要,
从底层去相信，
当我,
需要一些钱，
需要用钱干一些，
我真正想干的事的时候，
我总是会被支持的，
这个钱会出现的，
不管以什么形式，
我觉得这是真正的安全感，
然后我相信，
不管我的，
存款有多少，
高或低，
我都能有一个很好的生活，
我也不惧怕，
我由于失去很多钱，
或者我亏损了很多钱，
我就要完蛋了，
比如说你对水，
就是有安全感的，
什么叫对水有安全感，
第一,
你从来脑袋里不会想说，
我靠，今天可能要没水了，
然后第二，
你,
总是相信，
你需要水的时候，
你拧一个水龙头，
那水就会出来，
或者你需要水的时候，
接班会有一个店卖你水，
第三,
你不会有那种恐惧和匮乏，
说我靠，
我要再加吞20桶水，
否则的话，
我觉得很不踏实，
所以你在水这件事上，
就极其自由，
你懂我意思吗？
这就是，
终极的安全感是这样的，
用这个例子，
大家能理解我在说什么，
对吧?
我觉得这个是，
更终极的东西，
不管我要更多钱，
其实本账是需要有一个，
幸福的安全的生活，
那我还是那句话，
我会更固执的，
在这个层面上去工作，
你刚才形容，
金钱安全感的，
那几条里面，
最后一条，
我觉得我可以理解，
就是亏非常多的钱，
也不会觉得要完蛋了，
这个我觉得是可以理解的，
但是,
前面几条，
比如说在我需要，
用钱做我真正想做的事情的时候，
总会有的，
这个,
确实,
有一点，
这个已经不是，
现实物质层面，
原则是，
对,
我觉得我，
认识到了这个观念，
我试着在理解这个观念，
以及我，
看看我自己是不是能做到，
持有这个新年，
就是这样，
这是,
难道不是中级的自由吗？
是,
宇宙总会支持你，
就是这样，
就是,
就是我觉得，
我可能试着在这个层面去，
看待这个问题，
我都不敢说解决这个问题，
也不敢说，
我能达到什么样的境界，
都没有，
我就在尝试去，
以不同的方式，
去理解，
和看待金钱，
就这样，
然后,
至于他成不成功，
反正我自己感觉，
这是我想走的路，
体验一下，
而不是靠投资，
获得更多的钱，
来维持让你看，
我不是说不投资了，
我可能看到喜欢的股票，
或者我可能看到喜欢的公司，
我还会支持，
我也会做事情，
我觉得这个事，
很有意思，
我有灵感，
然后,
又是很好的人一起，
我就会去做，
但是,
还是那句话，
我回到这个基础的逻辑，
就是我不希望，
我做这些事的时候，
是出于恐惧的，
我刚才是在体会说，
就是这句话，
到底该怎么去理解，
因为我觉得，
你传达给我的感觉是，
你是希望说，
当你想要用金钱，
去做一些，
你真正特别小，
去做的事情，
而这个时候，
宇宙会以各种方式，
来支持你，
那金钱可能是，
其中的一种形式，
可是如果这句话，
只是从字面意思上，
来理解，
可能很多人，
容易把它趋解成，
那你是不是在鼓励大家，
去进行一些，
超钱消费啊，
或者是什么之类的，
啊，这个消费没关系，
因为,
不是啊，就是很简单，
就是你，
你是不是骗自己，
你自己知道啊，
你是很虚的在花，
还是你真实的，
不担忧的在花，
是,
你是骗不了自己的，
你懂我意思吗？
就一样嘛，
我是很清楚是，
你是真的需要一支，
爱马士包包，
还是,
你只是想模仿，
什么方式，
自己是知道的，
对啊，自己是知道的，
嗯,
就是这样，
就是我觉得，
一切的东西都建立在，
对自己，
完全的觉知和诚实上，
只要是诚实了，
就怎么都行，
你把诚实的骗自己，
我今天就想骗自己，
我明知道他要害我，
我就是想跟他谈恋爱，
没问题，
没任何问题，
因为,
人生就是来体验的，
你就要体验各种事，
就是你明知道，
跟这种人谈恋爱，
你肯定要被扎，
你第一次不知道，
第二次在模仿，
你第三次总知道了吧，
当你第三次仍然做重要选择的时候，
你就是实际上最自由的人，
因为你可以接受一切，
你不怕了，
你fear this,。
你无拒，无忧，
这才是真正的英雄主义，
对啊,
明明知道地方是个，
垃圾,
嗯,
还是上，
这不是去向最值得歌颂的品质吗，
勇敢,
自由的赞歌呀，
哈哈哈哈，
完了,
这是咱们这价值观，
越,
越聊越跑偏，
好，大家好，我是孟严，
哈哈哈哈，
不是,
我觉得还是那句话，
就是说，
如果当你真的想这么选，
你就这么选，
就是没有错了，
但是很多时候，
当你卸下这些，
恐惧,
匮乏这些东西，
你也不想，
瞎搞乱搞了，
你会自然的想去，
做一些你该做的事情，
我觉得这句话，
很有道理，
就很多时候，
你在做选择，
或者觉得自己别有选择的时候，
真的得问一下自己，
是不是在自己骗自己？
大部分人都在骗自己，
相信我，
因为这就是人，
每天都在自己骗自己，
但是,
骗一骗差不多了，
有一天，
你觉得，
是时候醒来的时候，
你就可以开始醒来了，
我觉得，
能听到这期节目，
并且听到这的人，
肯定,
咱们还是有点缘分，
不一定跟我，
但是你肯定还是有点会跟的，
没有会跟就要会跟，
好吧,
啊,
没有没有，
就是真的是这样，
就是,
我觉得，
我说这些，
其实,
根本,
我既没有在，
悲观,
放弃,
或者戏削都没有，
我就觉得，
很妙,
哇,
这声很妙，
刚才我不知道，
为什么来这个世界上，
我就觉得很框妙，
我现在，
有点答案了，
就是要体验，
这些乱七八糟的事，
很妙，你不觉得，
滚滚红尘，
滚滚红尘就贼辣有意思 整天就是不是给你搞一个栽的坑 就是给你发来一个不会的事让你去学 然后今天可能又。
这个明天都那个 然后你还得有天还得生病 疼 反正都是很多命定的体验 咱们就是通过这个东西来。
来了解自己 来借甲修真呗。
就这样嘛 还能干嘛呀 闲点闲着。
反正就是最后大家都会死的 真的没关系 人都是要死的。
死了 转世还得来 你没上辈子没完的课题 这辈子还得回来修 就不能存玩吗？
就在更宏观的角度讲 在在这个一的角度讲 这就是玩。
这就是他体验自我的方式 不是你在体验生活。
是宇宙在通过你体验他自己。
不是你在体验世界 是世界通过你在体验他自己。
你只是这一切发生的场域。
并不是你在干这些事 只是生活通过你发生了。
虽然我不理解 但是我觉得这句话很有意思。
最好不理解 因为你理解了就开始用脑子了 不理解才进入你的心。
一套一套的 是吧？
就是一套一套的 是吧？
不是真的是这样 用钱是用今生的。
以前是用今生的 不真的是这样。
所以宇宙的信号这次把你送来小酒馆。
你现在站在这样的一个节点 看有者有谁也好 看小酒馆也好。
你作为一个最早的发起人 你的感觉是什么？
没啥感觉
真的 我能参谋就参谋一点 我参谋不上就看人的成长呗 没啥有啥感觉的 没啥感觉。
有让你感到意外的部分吗？
没什么意外的 并且 一切都在计划中。
那肯定不是 没什么意外的 并不是在计划中。
而是我觉得 每个东西都会成长它本来的样子。
而你们就在成长成你们本来的样子。
当然 如果我自大一点的说的话。
我实际上能感受到 我来参谋一点 我什么时候应该来参谋一下。
然后我正好这次感觉 可能参谋了一下。
但是就像我说的 我根本不在意支撑小酒馆。
长成什么样 其实我主要是参谋一下你。
然后这个东西在未来就会变成小酒馆的一些别的变化。
现在我们都不知道会发生什么 但是这不就是命运吗？
如果因为我今天说的一些东西导致之后 这节目越做越差。
那就是我就是你的命运杀猪盘。
你就是我的报应 我就是你的报应 我该找咱们有这处。
然后你就成长了 反应必有股 我的报应就是你。
对 你的报应就是我 对吧 所以就我们都接受命运。
然后热爱命运就行了。
love your fate 热爱你的命运。
好 这期就聊到这。
好 新高采烈的结束了 感谢宇白 感谢肖宇老师。
好好好 大家拜拜 下期不知道什么再见。